bien alors votre livre s'appelle le
passeur de miroirs 7 aux presses du
châtelet
ça commence comme ça enfin c'est la page
9 je me souviens quand j'avais 5 ans mon
père possédait un manoir de granit gris
et j'ai appris un jour que je serais
peut-être roi ce livre c'est un peu
qu'est ce qu'être un roi un à travers un
conte philosophique initiatique
vous avez choisi ce style de conte
philosophique en rapport avec les
lettres persanes avec des choses comme
ça parce que vous reprochez l'époque
d'avoir un langage trop aseptisé c'est
ça nous sommes dans le politiquement
correct et moi j'aime ma la liberté la
liberté d'expression et donc c'est la
seule façon d'avoir une certaine liberté
chez de prendre de cette forme de conte
philosophique
la visite que l'époque moderne l'homme
enfin l'individu a un peu perdu son âme
et vous n'êtes pas pour un retour en
arrière vous n'êtes pas attiré que j'ai
eu tellement à lutter contre votre père
toute façon qu'on peut penser que vous
avez quand même un certain sens de la
liberté même s'ils voulaient pas le dire
parce que vous respectez votre père ce
qui est normal mais c'est vrai que vous
avez un certain sens de la liberté aux
états pour un retour en arrière vous
n'êtes pas quelqu'un de réactionnaire
n'est pas quelqu'un de deux
conservateurs d'ailleurs on peut dire
que les orléans alors des charges après
tout ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
les orléans ont toujours été très
libéraux et ben rapport aux par rapport
à la branche aînée au bond de la branche
aînée les jantes et même parfois à la
pointe du progrès parce que je ne me
souviens que sous
louis saez sont d'abord les orléans
clients qui ont eu les premiers vaccins
ouais pour la paris absolument
mais c'est quoi les châteaux que qu'ils
ont eue parce que si j'ai envie d'un
jour d'aller dans un château et dire moi
je le connais le mec mais c'est vrai il
ya des chefs vous allez j'en ai plein de
château d'amboise points avoue amboise
encore mais c'était ça vous encore ouais
ok je peux venir de ces gav way s'est
gâté c'est monseigneur qui va dit avec
la caravane non parce qu'il nous fait
pleurer avec la situation dramatique du
mec qui a le château d'amboise à mais
non ils appartiennent à une fondation
oui si c'est nous les gens visitent mais
c'est comme changer mon seigneur comme
chambly mais bon gentil voilà c'est une
fondation étonnant ils ont donné des
trucs gentils votre votre père puis à sa
décharge a quand même fait beaucoup pour
les personnes âgées
donc vous êtes vous n'êtes pas comme je
disais vous n'étiez pas très
conservateur vous n'êtes pas pour un
retour derrière vous êtes vous appelez
ça une écologie divine c'est quoi une
écologie divine nous sommes entourés par
quand même une nature que nous n'avons
pas créé c'est quelqu'un d'autre qui l'a
créé et il faut la respecter et donc je
dis qu'il faut savoir respecter toutes
ces lois de la nature
regardez tout ce qui se passe maintenant
et c'est marrant parce que plus j'écoute
et puis ça m'intéresse
vous pensez quoi qu envoyé l'espagne qui
est l'exemple d'une monarchie qui marche
bien ou le maroc
ou quand vous voyez l'angleterre la
hollande la suède pardon il fallut un
message vous pensez quoi qu'on est
toutes ces monarchies européennes parce
que je crois en europe si à moissy des
pays de l'europe qui sont des monarchies
ou pensez quoi
cela pourrait marcher en france où la
france est définitivement cuit non je
pense que tout toute solution est à
envisager un jour parce que regarder
actuellement la droite la gauche c'est
un peu blanc bonnet bonnet blanc
lundi il faut il faut supprimer les pari
loterie guy dit qu'on va remettre les
ogm
bon on va dans une une société
complètement folle alors il faut un jour
mettre un peu d'ordre dans tout cela
ouais bon je vois que il ya un certain
ordre en espagne et en angleterre il y
en a en belgique au maroc
je connais bien aujourd'hui
le petit roi que je trouve très policé
m6 ben oui j'ai mêlé aux cadors m6 a
ouais non 6